oh my god I'm running out that would hit
me
covergirl Mraz - beautify Dave we're
gonna play with some Oh oh if you're
ready plus space why not
oh it's pretty calm so far not much of a
horror to be honest
Oh second floor hi oh god take me home
Oh feels good that was amazing I think
if I was Iron Man I just got [ __ ]
alright next floor Oh Jake says [ __ ]
dick in it nice hey Carol well what I
named it a touch huh I have there I have
the power of hand I know it the gods
have spoken on my hand I knew all those
hand jobs would pay off what okay then
this is a weird elevator this is not an
elevator is it it's this Pratt Punk'd
it's actually Kutcher gonna come out
what what am i controlling this oh oh
don't [ __ ] with my brain like eight oh
god what is going on oh my god I just
blew my mind
oh I hope that's my belly oh god don't
hug me now don't slap a why would you
slap me stop slap that's right
I killed her I am the best oh my god so
scared that looks amazing
it's almost as real oh god there's a
hand I find - your hand
Oh God you look so pretty come here come
here
ah come on that was maybe not the
scariest one ain't played but it was fun
it was a lot of fun
so this games supposed to be a
recreation of brandy the movie I can't
wait to hang out with Sandra Balak
oh my craft oh my god Sandra Balak where
are you
Sandra Sandra Sandra whoa
open the bye don't know how oh I did it
what all right this is happening oh I
have this arrow thing go to the spa
station all right and um I like to think
that I'm farting forward but I don't
think that's it
Oh God oh no George Clooney where I oh
ah oh god oh god huh whoa whoa chill the
[ __ ] out
till the [ __ ] out I'm gonna die it it's
a beautiful left ahh
come on if said a bullet can do it I can
[ __ ] do it why am I going towards the
space station even though it's exploded
how many times can the space station
explode Oh God
I take it back almost thank you party ah
oh my god I'm running out that one hit
me
are you serious warning less oxygen but
I'm trying enough breathing at all
mission complete
I don't know what I did press but I did
it and I feel good about it I held that
X button for almost two minutes straight
that would that was that was a time well
[ __ ] I didn't even get to see George
Clooney but hey hey you win some you
lose some
am i right it's time to go sliding baby
oh yeah girl oh yeah yeah alright well
we're gonna top that [ __ ] yes oh god
what am I going hey can we do a 360 we
can't well [ __ ] a bad idea then I feel
so happy and Daffy doing controlling
like this ah yes oh god oh oh god oh wow
oh god it goes faster and faster holy
[ __ ] oh my god oh god oh god what is ow
what is this Oh for the love of God oh
my god I got a heart attack no no oh my
god don't ever do that am i naked I'm
[ __ ] naked why did I not realize this
is amazing ha ha ha ha ha come on I wish
I saw that I would have changed
everything ok so this game I have
actually played before
I just never played it with the VR oh my
god yes sitting on the toilet sitting on
the toilet
now flourish this is the best gaming
experience of my life
and I'm not exaggerating a lot now the
real question is can I take a [ __ ] I
don't remember
come on I thought for sure I could [ __ ]
what is this
I'm not immersed if this is it I might
as well just go to my toilet all right
impress me oh I am impressed all right
oh sweet Jesus Matilda what did I guess
filet Oh can I do a double up yes I'm
doubling up best game of my entire life
that was future technology has all led
up to this moment
broseph you have an oculus rift you have
to try this one out
holy [ __ ] larly we will soon be praising
over [ __ ] like stuff we got a climbing
game all right what do we got here um I
guess I go here and I put my hand there
Oh for the love of God what is happening
over there oh thank god
all right oh yes Yas pitch and then yes
and yes climbing it yes oh my god how am
I doing this oh yeah I'm talking close
to this oh I didn't know my hands could
do that that's pretty good ah ah I broke
every bone in my body I will never walk
it I'm fine I got this is giving me
motion sickness [ __ ] that ah some games
just give me a lot more motion sickness
than others I think it's the shitty ones
actually not all shitty ones my god
no freakin way
I take back this is greater than toilet
simulator I never thought I'd say that
but it's true so I just woke up in my
all my gosh it's it's so weird
ow oh my god I am not play this gaming
forever either this is some weird [ __ ]
the childhood the childhood feels
I wish the NPC's were here I don't see
them oh my god oh my god oh my god ah
holy [ __ ] this is even scarier in VR ah
Jesus
oh my god ah that's not okay I didn't
see it there we go did it it it it it it
it it it it it it it it [ __ ] you ran
through the shops no oh well that's a
pretty damn cool thing though I gotta
say if you could play like entire
ocarina of time on their VR would be so
cool but anyway that's all the time I
had for today bros thank you for leaving
a like and commenting as always that's
for you you little shampoo